today's show is all about that extra
time and we're rolling out never
before seen bonus footage and segments
you might say this episode is a little
bit
extra so first up
when we talk to the wonderful talented
beautiful anne hathaway
we confess that we totally have huge
crushes on each other
and we had a big love fest but there are
some things that you didn't get to see
so take a look i
fell into romantic comedies
and i realized that that was a genre
that i was really happy being in
and oh thank you well
crazy dream girl excellent in oh thank
you
i i just loved putting positive things
out into the world but i was always
cognizant and i'm not a calculated
person i am
very heart first i didn't think about
money i didn't think about
career i didn't have that ambition but
what i think is so interesting
is you you can get sort of pigeonholed
in hollywood of like oh you're this
genre and the thing that i love
about you or anybody and i talk about it
all the time
the range you are in all these films
that we love so much that we love to
cozy into but then you're in like
indies like rachel getting married and
then you're in les miz
winning an oscar but it's still ella
enchanted devil wears product bride wars
you've managed to transcend like not
being
pigeonholed in any way you can do modern
love and sing and dance you can be in
the witches with this extraordinary
accent
and i feel like you've done such an
amazing job at creating a ride that
anyone will get on and believe
the genre tone and story that you are
telling without saying i know what this
is going to be
and that's not easy to do thank you i'm
i'm
i could be silent and and just absorb
that for
a lot longer but that wouldn't be very
fun for your audience so i'm just going
to
thank you so much i can't tell you what
that means to me i'll probably email you
about it later
but um but i honestly thank you you're
giving me way
too much credit i think when you look at
all of those films you have to look at
the directors
who just kind of because you know how it
is we do our best we we give the raw
material
to them but then it takes on a whole
other life and the director is the one
that
guides it and edits it and and then you
know kind of guides the music that goes
on top of it and
um and so when i think of those
performances i think
that's the reason why i maybe if i've to
this point
it's to avoid being pigeonholed it has
to be because i've just had such
incredible directors protecting me
and i'm making sure that it felt
different i think that's an excellent
point
i am i love directors um
and they do really mold and they set the
tone
like you're a wonderful director oh my
gosh
thank you director is that is that
something that you love are we going to
see more of that i'm sorry i mean to put
you on the spot but
no i i had i had my kids and you know
the directing job and i'm so psycho
about everything i do
that i just i had to stop for a while i
wanted to like
you know just raise my kids for a while
and then
i went back to work in this show called
santa clarita diet and it was like
such a blessing because it you know
what i mean just like candy you could
just i can just watch you forever
you're just like what you were saying
about wanting to put happiness out there
that is exactly when i'm
i like just like scrolling through
channels and i come on and i see your
face
i'm just so happy it gives me the best
feeling and i always stop because i
gotta see what you're up to
in the scene it doesn't matter how many
times i've seen it and so anyway i
didn't mean to cut you off but you're
great in santa clarita diet oh my god
thank you so much i'm i first of all i'm
amazed and thrilled that you
know what it is a i watch television yes
i know i'm amazed by myself too
but it like it reminded me that i had a
skill set because i had totally lost it
like i had become
so kid-oriented that i kind of forgot
who i was
and it was nice to be reminded that
i you know because also if you psycho
stare your kid in the face they're going
to end up in therapy so it was like
there was a anyway drew come on we got
to just
don't worry about that except inevitable
you're so right what do you think you're
going to uh send your kids into therapy
over
um i actively avoid thinking about it
so i'm not too worried i'm not i'm not i
don't hopefully we're not there yet
hopefully we are not there yet
but to your point about like the way you
kind of give over to
motherhood and then you remember who you
are i feel like i'm i'm going through
something similar like that right now
and it's it's a funny thing and i hope
we get there as a culture that we
because i feel like we talk about these
things as though there are specific line
breaks
as opposed to another thing which is
like this accumulation this accumulation
of life experience and wisdom
and and each and everything builds on
each other and there's like a
layering involved to it and um i just i
just think that
uh i don't know i just hope we get to
that point where
because i think that i don't know why
exactly maybe it's because there's this
history uh
you know of looking at ourselves in
these specific ways
and we're just getting to a point where
we're more
relaxed and accepting that we're we're
all sorts of different things and they
and whether or not you have kids is is
you know that that's not actually
relevant to this conversation but
but that way of seeing each other as
whole beings who do many many different
things
i completely agree and i talk about how
there are so many
facets of a person within a day of a
life
let alone an entire life we have
chapters in our books
so i'm really really glad to hear you
say that
yeah and i think this show is one of the
re what i was so excited about
uh when i found out that you were doing
this show in addition to just being
excited because as i said i am
i do have a big crush on you is uh was
this because you're such a curious
person and you
always led with that like and having
been a fan for a really long time that's
who that's one of the main adjectives
that i think of when i think of you is
you're just so
curious and what a cool thing to now
have
an entire team working alongside of you
to explore that curiosity and then kind
of
i don't know bring bring what you find
to the rest of us
ann also recently revealed that she
prefers to be called
annie so thank you annie